oh hey guys my name is Eric I'm new here
so I thought I'd make some friends
around the office by giving people a
little treat I grew up with in Russia
chocolate with a full shot of vodka more
they call let's go get it
welcome to Russia town
[Music]
let's go make some friends
chocolate with the bagel
now when you say you're trying to make
friends around the office that makes me
think that this is gonna make from some
pretty gnarly stuff right here I guess
that's the best way to make from the
friends I give him a random chocolate
cup if I'm being stereotypical ask you
I'm expecting like really strong dark
chocolate every vodka in it potato's
cyanide
it's not even noon I hope that's not
vodka I really hope it's not like
expecting me very unhappy again that's
good I just chocolate the chocolate
itself is good I think I just was so
expecting a creamy Center caramel is the
night this is a really good good texture
goodbye
yeah hey Russia what's going on I know
we're having some difficult times
between us right now but I really think
he kind of starts on this over here I
feel like we can kind of work our
differences out so I want more friends
so I'm just gonna run around the office
and give this chocolate to anyway if I
get your new best friends we're gonna
party with some of this later you want
to get chocolate drop 50 micron you like
it are we best friends over
how do you say cheers in Russian miss
don't miss that olya that's Dave diver
knows that audio now does NASA
nostrovia ester oh yeah
[Music]